welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
today we have got alex bazie and stan
lake again
we wanted to go down the rabbit hole on
capsule networks
do you remember capsule networks the
thing that jeffrey hinton
invented in 2011 or so everyone talks a
good game about capsule networks but
can we really use them and how do they
work
these are some of the things that we're
going to be wrestling with in today's
episode but for the first half an hour
or so
we talk about chapter 7 of kenneth
stanley's
why greatness can't be planned now this
book is hugely inspirational for me but
it's also a bit divisive because keith
does not
share my love of this book i hope you
like comment and subscribe
don't forget and we'll see you back next
week
welcome back today with my two compadres
mit doctor keith
duggar and alex bayesian
sten lake how's it going guys
wonderful it's an excellent evening he
stole the bayesian title
now that's just yeah well in today's
episode we wanted to cover a couple of
things so first of all
we spoke about the algo shambles a few
weeks ago
and a lot of that was talking about how
the government wanted to standardize the
grades
in the uk and i've been reading a really
interesting book by kenneth stanley
called greatness cannot be planned and
and his philosophy is essentially that
we have a tyranny of objectives and
objectives are
the worst possible form of group think
that when you have objectives it
completely stifles innovation and also
it completely disrupts the system
because everything becomes about the
objective
and when you try to directly optimize an
it causes all sorts of strange side
effects
so i've got uh chapter seven of why
greatness cannot be planned
and uh he quotes campbell's law which is
well known in the social sciences it
says
the more any quantitative social
indicator is used for social decision
making
the more subject it will be to
corruption pressures and the more apt it
will be
to distort and corrupt social processes
it's intended to monitor it's a staple
it's a the more you use a metric as a
target
the less it's valid as a metric is like
a watch word in
any sort of quantitative social science
domain anyone that's self-aware enough
to
be wary of such traps yeah but i think
this is more just about
making sure that the objectives are
designed
in such a way that they correlate in a
meaningful way
to whatever it is we're trying to
achieve as a as a society
let's just simplify it suppose uh we're
back in
back and say the earl in the 1940s or
1930s where we actually had
people who were computers calculating
running calculations for us
and suppose i go okay hey i'm gonna have
this
objective where we give you this test
and we see how many numbers you can add
together
and in 30 minutes and then based off of
that we're gonna hire the top
whatever twenty percent would we be
complaining if
their instructors and teachers were
manipulating them to perform better and
better
on that exam no because they're actually
just causing them to perform better and
better at the actual job that they're
gonna that they're gonna do
so the objective is very closely tied to
what they actually need to do to be
productive
or what society needs them to do for
some particular application
great manipulate away so i think
stan lee's thesis is that there's a
couple of problems with these kind of
grand optimization schemes and
one is deception so he says that every
grand optimization problem has deception
and also a lot of people think in this
metric world we think that
we should be able to directly measure
improvement and
if we continuously measure improvement
between where we are now and where our
goal is it will monotonically increase
there's no acceptance that sometimes
things have to get worse
before they get better a classic example
of this is the so-called chinese finger
trap and this is uh what stanley he
cites this many times in his book he
says
the economy could be stuck in a chinese
finger trap
a decrease might be needed to produce a
much larger increase
in fact economists recognize that
relying too heavily on gdp makes little
sense
while in practice it's the most widely
touted economic indicator
this paradox has been called gdp
fetishism
so just like test scores indicators like
gdp can become
less meaningful as they are directly
optimized
there's there is like some logic here
though right
that if we do have a simple task and we
know it well enough
we can quantitize it and put a metric on
it and directly optimize for that
but stanley even grants here that
generally the sorts are simple like
there is a place for these simple
indicators and it's for simple tasks
and the sorts of problems maybe
calculating at a certain speed
is a simple task but what happens when
you come up against that limit
and you need to find a new way to
calculate numbers faster
he's kind of point the or the makes
within this chapter is that
you can optimize up to a point but if
you need to make that jump to a new
technique then relying on the numbers
just keeps you trapped because
you can't you don't have the space for
the rethink that may be required
that's it's not to say that it's useless
but maybe because
i do i do like keith keith's example
because it seems like
that's just cognitive ability and there
are no shortcuts because there's so many
things
it for example the the way that the
teachers generate the tests
maybe there's some pattern to it and the
students will essentially
memorize how to pass this test and that
they don't
really pull the questions and they get a
hold of the questions ahead of time and
memorize all 250 of them
even though there's only 50 on the test
but no but the other thing too
is and we did read that book and i
thought a lot of it was prevented
presented in a very kind of false
dilemma kind of way
like you have to do either one or the
other and i don't i think
it look i think people have for as long
as people been around there's always
been the crazy inventor that's trying to
violate the second law of thermodynamics
or whatever
and the garage like bill gates in his
garage
doing something innovative and he was a
dropout
right from harvard it's not like we ban
that activity we do
both things at the same time as a
civilization we have objectives
and we may have some very rigid kind of
procedures that are
optimizing a way and they get however
far they get and then they hit a dead
end or deadlock but at the same time
there are innovators out there thinking
outside the box in parallel
coming up with alternative systems and
then once those
are once those are born then they get
optimized in the same way that the
previous ones do and at some point they
surpass
like prior technologies right like this
both are happening
in parallel and i i think they're useful
in different regimes too if
taking the example of education if we're
looking at
preventing school or helping schools
that are in real trouble those sorts of
quantitative indicators are pretty good
because the problem here is there are
probably funding problems
skills problems that need to be
rectified but if we're talking about
like how to push
things forward there's like a transition
zone where the numbers the the metrics
become less and less useful
and i i think that the argument that
it is a false dilemma and that there is
room for both of these approaches i
think that has a lot of merit
that's true i mean this is about
treasure hunting i think keith stanley's
big point is that we need to be treasure
hunters
and we need to sometimes go in the way
which seems antithetical to the
direction
towards our objectives he cites the
example of steve job he says that
even steve jobs said he had no idea what
he wanted to do he did exactly what he
wanted to do
which was to explore it's just that in
our culture exploring without a clear
objective seems so flawed
and misguided that not even steve jobs
had the word to say it positively
who knows what the next generation might
discover without the weight of all of
the usual milestones and plans upon them
so when somebody comes along and says um
hey look there's this great idea
and it's a silver bullet that 100 solves
every problem
it's hard sometimes to frame an argument
against that because i'm not saying it
never works
i'm just saying it's not the the panacea
so there are plenty of counter examples
so in my mind
the the space program of the united
states let's say in the 60s when kennedy
just set an objective
to land a man on the moon before the
decade was out
that's an objective and i don't even
know how many people
and and amounts of money was for us
towards that objective in many different
paths
innovative paths optimization paths et
cetera
and then ultimately we got a man on the
moon and furthermore that program has
spurred all kinds of
innovation and development of other
technologies that nobody thought ahead
of time
that they would need but they came up
with because they were trying to achieve
this objective
so it's just not black and white this is
this falls in the bucket to me of
old ideas that are presented as new
ideas that are silver bullets because
we've been doing this for a long time
maybe not in the same names
let's just take a simple example ant
colony optimization for example right
it's a very simple
algorithm where you have these agents
that that
start off randomly looking around and
when they find something some resource
that they need like sugar or something
then they go back to the colony and when
they move around they leave behind a
little pheromone trail that
that decays right but they're also
encoded to occasionally
have errors like instead of following
the path to just branch off
somewhere else in search of novelty
right and sort of new resources
i feel like you know these aren't the
droids you're looking for like there's
there's nothing
really new here you're talking about
exploration versus exploitation but
stanley makes the argument that linking
those two together still creates
a convergent search not a divergent
search
yeah it's the convergence that's the
problem and there are alternatives here
like
explicitly coding for exploration as a
goal
that's a far more open-ended sort of
thing to
thinking about like designing products
or designing
solutions to a problem there are certain
techniques people apply
involving reframing how you think about
the problem
moving from how do we just do this thing
better
but the key example here is steve jobs
it's not how do we make a better mp3
player
it's how do we help people enjoy music
more framing the problem in a more
open-ended term
does give you an objective right it does
give you something that you can navigate
by it gives you your man on the moon
by the end of the decade but it's not so
restrictive in that it
locks you into a particular path to get
there if they said oh
we need to make the saturn 3 rocket you
know powerful enough to do it
they may not have discovered the saturn
fives or like
it may have locked out certain
technological paths
it would be interesting to see if that
can be
like fully operationalized within
reinforcement learning
research or whether or not that's just a
nightmare of
non-convergent algorithm that never do
anything remotely useful
but i'd like to think maybe there is
some some merit in this idea of goals
without
convergence goals without fixed
solutions just
trying to make problems more open-ended
more generally
yeah we're going to do a follow-up show
on this anyway but in stanley's book he
gives loads of examples in maze solving
for example where
by directly optimizing for solving the
maze you shoot yourself in the foot
and the best way to solve the maze is
are these kind of quality diversity type
algorithms or
novelty search algorithms but let's also
talk about the issue of perverse
incentives because i think that's quite
interesting he says here that
another extreme form of campbell's law
which we just cited before
is a perverse incentive he cites the
example of india during british rule
the government tried to exterminate
venomous snakes by paying citizens for
every dead snake they handed over
but it didn't work out very well it led
to citizens breeding cobras just to kill
them for bounty
and ultimately the number of venomous
snakes in india went up
and there are other examples of this so
in hanoi the same thing happened with
rats so the the policy didn't lead to
fewer rats but it led to
rat farms and then again he cites in the
book here that
aiming to reduce abusing drugs can
result in
the paradoxical increase paying workers
for each fragment of dinosaur bones will
lead to
folks smashing the bones paying
executives with bonuses for higher
earnings leads to
short-term profits but longer-term
disaster so
he says here that these examples show
that deception isn't confined to
algorithms and evolution it's very
widespread
yeah but we've had mathematics to think
about and and find
ways to to better frame problems for
that's game theory
like how do i set how do i set a kind of
payoff or
system or whatever to achieve the goal
that i want to achieve without these
kinds of
shenanigans and just bring it back to
the algo shambles
in their 15 right if you have fewer than
15 students
in the class we do algorithm a if it's
more than 15 we do
algorithm b that's going to create all
kinds of perverse incentives like the
one we brought up was
now all of a sudden they have an
incentive to keep their class size at
15. so if it's more than 15 maybe
they're going to split it up or
if they're already at 15 and some new
student
wants to join the school too bad don't
have room for you
maybe a solution there would have been
to do something where it's this weighted
combination
like it's why it's the number of
students
divided by 15 or some kind of linear
kind of progression between algorithm a
and algorithm b
and then that way there's no clear cut
off there or some non-linear combination
of things i'm sure a game theory expert
could tell us
how to design that to where they
wouldn't be perversely incentivized to
do it at exactly
15. it would be very hard for them to
figure out
whether or not it was actually ever
beneficial for them to restrict the
class size or not
i agree with you on that but on
standardizing test
scores i think the idea there was all
about being able to compare
if someone in birmingham is doing badly
that would be somewhat comparable to
someone in london
but again he points out in this book
that obsession with standardized tests
in education
can result in improvements mostly in
test taking skills and memorization it's
not really
helping the kids learn the subject but
it's also demoralizing it reduces the
autonomy of the teachers right because
if they
come up with something innovative they
can't really share those innovations
with their colleagues they're just
it's almost like a tyranny of the
standardized tests and being forced to
to think in this kind of monolithic way
yeah i think we're moving the goal posts
here and changing contacts so i
i'm specifically talking about the
perverse incentive of having a magic
number
in a in a formula used for significant
social
social outcomes i'm saying we can avoid
those quite
easily without trashing our idea of
objectives or mathematical formulas
and going to some brand new
non-convergent social system
we don't have to do that i i call
shenanigans here
just because like game theory is a
useful tool undoubtedly
and properly thinking through how we
structure these things does have
advantages
but then there's always an incentive to
cheat and
maths no matter how well structured
can't
always capture the subtlety nuance and
variety of human behavior
like that would be a heck of an equation
to really write something that
is unbreakable in this sort of system
uh it's not that i don't think it's a
good idea to apply what we know
to these problems and try and reduce
perverse incentives to try and reduce
people gaming the system but i
don't see it as really feasible i i just
think there's too many edge cases that
need to be considered and accounted for
and even then people will come up with
things that no one sitting around the
table designing this thing
will have actually thought of i'm always
an advocate
of simplicity and i've seen too many
examples
of where very simple slight changes to
the scheme
actually eliminated the sort of perverse
incentive problems
and i'm going to probably get some of
these details wrong but before
the united states had before
prescription drugs were covered by
federal medicare there were states that
were experimenting with kind of paying
for them
themselves i think one state was
washington or oregon or somewhere
and so they they started covering
prescription drugs and
then of course doctors get all these uh
lavish trips to hawaii and sort of
things by drug manufacturer
to sell their new version of aspirin for
50 times as much so that doesn't even
really work that much better
and so they had this cost overrun right
this problem of all this
stuff getting prescribed instead of just
the cheap generics so the modification
they made to the system was extremely
simple they just said okay fine
you can still prescribe whatever
medication you think is best for your
patients however
if it's not on this kind of list of best
bang for the buck
medications that we've created you need
to fill out a few paragraphs justifying
why they need this other medication and
just making the doctors spend
a few minutes of their time filling out
paragraphs
virtually eliminated this problem right
so
there are these little clever things and
sometimes you have to just
experimentally try them out
but i'm just saying we can we've been
able to do that
well before this book was written so we
don't need a novelty search to achieve
this
that's really interesting if you think
that we could analytically figure out
where people are taking shortcuts and
abusing the system and then just
redesign the system to stop that from
happening
do tests do a b testing right try it out
we have to test because look i agree
with you alex this is
far too complex for any maths to solve
including the math of novelty search
so we just have to test and be clever
but but even then it might
because we have a similar problem with
machine learning algorithms they take
shortcuts and do weird things and
perverse things happen and unintended
consequences
but here you might find that in
birmingham because of some
colloquial cultural thing something
happens and then in london something
else happens and
how would you even come up with a best
solution that that works as well as it
can do
distributed government no
one-size-fits-all
solution yeah well look we probably know
as
as scientists and engineers right the
only scalable control systems are
distributed
like we shouldn't be trying to build yet
greater monolithic
monopolistic government systems they we
need to go back to distributing more the
power to
lower layers of our governmental network
if you will
indeed but i must admit though i am
signed on to stanley's thesis in general
i am a big believer that this this
concept of treasure hunting
is a really good one and by having group
think we can really be cutting ourselves
off and i want to just show
an image from from his book so this is
talking about pick breeder i won't go
into too much detail on this because
we're going to cover it properly i'm
even making a video about it but the
idea
is you can go to this website called
picbreeder.com and even you're
putting them on your wall you're getting
some of those lately printed out
absolutely
and behind the scenes it's using uh
compositional pattern producing networks
and then you can choose a couple of
parents and you can breed them together
and it creates
a new stepping stone and the it serves a
really illustrative point here because
human humans go onto this
pickpretter.com and they all and they
get bored after a while but they'll
breed a whole bunch of images that they
like
and probably humans have certain priors
about the types of images that they like
so they probably have a
kind of anthropocentric or even
heliocentric view of what looks good
but the core concept is that all of the
intermediate stepping stones look
nothing like the objective
if you try to breed a skull from the
beginning
you would not be able to make a skull
and the same goes for so many things if
you wanted to make computers
you wouldn't have realized that you
needed to create valves before and
people did spend 10 years making valves
before they made computers
so in almost every single problem we
have this notion that
the metric needs to monotonically
increase between where we are now and
where we want to end up
and actually there's this concept called
the false compass which means
we do not know what the intermediate
stepping stones are between where we are
now and where we want to go
that more or less i made the argument
that i'd make that sometimes metrics are
useful
they're a guiding light but where we
start to take them as
as the thing with which we're testing
against when we lose sight of the fact
that
they're metrics they're not targets
that's where the problems start
like i live in china obviously it's not
too bad here in the south of the country
at the moment but a couple of years ago
in beijing
the pollution was horrible like it you'd
breathe outside and it would hurt your
lungs
and that that was a result of like
rampant gdp targeting
now they do some interesting things here
on a social level in terms of
distributed government and experimenting
and that's not something that
you tend to associate with you think of
china you think oh big government
it's still very it's almost futile in
structure right there's a lot of
distributed authority
a lot of experimentation going on and
it's only just recently that they've
woken up to the fact that hey
chasing all these numbers it got us to a
point
but now we have all these other problems
that we need to deal with the
significantly threatening things and
certainly in
some of the more interesting
organizations i've had the pleasure of
like working alongside and chatting to
over the years
the ones that recognize the value of
metrics
but don't take them too seriously that
kind of know
when to ignore them they've they tend to
do more innovative things
they tend to be a bit more freewheeling
and they tend to
feel like they're going further yeah
like i'm not saying let's throw out
the books per se i'm not saying let's go
to a complete freewheeling version
i think you're right with the
distributing authority like distributing
decision making down to the people who
are actually affected by things
so that they can find unique solutions
to their particular problems
not building a monolithic system is a
good thing being able to keep an eye on
things is good
but the the more we rigorously move
things to like very tight metrics
the more we're gonna move towards that
big centralized model where one case
must fit all
and uh i guess that's i guess that's the
crux of the
of campbell's argument as i read it so i
want to comment on that pick breeder
because
okay he's saying when people use my
system pick breeder and they go in the
way that they would naturally go they
just don't end up with what they want to
like okay is that a comment on something
fundamental about the universe or just
to comment on let's say the basis
functions within pick breeder
suppose the classic portrait artist
right like
when rembrandt went to paint a portrait
did he grab a paint brush that randomly
splayed
curved stuff on his canvas and then
tried to combine them in some wacky way
to get a portrait no he just started
building it up
piece by piece with a precise instrument
and ended up with fantastic realistic
beautiful portraits right but you've
just proven my point yeah
because the thing is anything wonderful
which we want is not designed
it is discovered
furthermore when you're teaching someone
how to paint the first thing you do is
you stop trying to get them to
paint the object and start to paint the
shapes
the pieces you teach them techniques
like you teach them how to put ink on or
paint on a page to
achieve certain small effects and then
over time they learned how to combine
those pieces into a hole
i i can't draw to save my life but but
if i'm trying to draw you two guys
i'm gonna start drawing faces and stuff
like that but
everyone i know that has any sort of
talent says nah you gotta forget about
that you need to think in this way
that's counterintuitive it's
opposite of how you think you'd learn to
draw and eventually yeah you start
worrying about the details but that's
because you've got all these
abstractions
that are necessarily a step away from
the direct route to what you want
i i i do i do see both of your points
though because
there are certain skills for example if
you want to paint you need to know how
to paint
you need to know about brush strokes and
you need to be able to use a canvas and
so on
but that's just the substrate it's
similar to it
for us to exploit planet earth we need
to be able to breathe air and we need to
be able to
see and then it means that we can
largely exploit the earth
but once you have that substrate or base
of skills
then you need to do what might appear to
be completely backwards or random things
completely
counter-intuitive to what you know in
order to make progress
and in that sense then we can't really
plan very far ahead at all
we can only take intermediate stepping
stones and the ones that we take might
seem
completely backwards yeah i guess i'm
just not on the same page here
because if i was rembrandt and i was
gonna paint a portrait he's going to
start off by doing a rough sketch
and uh and pencil very lightly there
using all the techniques he's learned
about say
symmetry of human faces how to do
strokes that result in certain patterns
on the page is going to build it up but
even some larger scale things like
a motion to draw sort of a nice curved
outline of the face etc
and then he's going to know now he needs
to start applying paint and
work from the back to the front
algorithmically with the background
and combining strokes when we go to
build a bridge a building anything like
this is all what engineering is about is
how do we break down
analytically and codify the processes
into repeatable
modules if you will to achieve that goal
now that's different it's already been
achieved
yeah but it is art an algorithm
so i mean would any artist make a good
engineer or are there
patterns of thinking completely
different i don't know but that's not
the point about pig breeder
you could take a rembrandt and now we
can do engineering on it
just like we do in software engineering
projects we can do a waterfall
methodology
we can struggle we've got one guy doing
these strokes and we break it down into
the that's completely different but at
some point someone discovered
how to paint in that way yeah but in
pick reader he makes this comment that
when people use this tool set
using their natural proclivities they
don't end up with what they want
well here's the thing when people use
the toolset of the real world
using our natural proclivities we end up
with what we want
but we don't know what we want if we
know what we want then we've already
found it
uh the whole point of this is that
there's an infinite space out there
of possible innovations and inventions
and
some of them are only one step away
there's a treasure hunt that's what he
says there's all of these things that
we've got
and we can use these things to to take
one stepping stone away
and we can find something amazing but we
have no conception of what they are yet
otherwise we'd go and do them
i'm just attacking this pick breeder
argument i'm saying that the fact that
people interacting with pick breeder in
the whatever this way that comes natural
to them
doesn't end up with cool paintings says
nothing about uh novelty search
like if i if i give you you know a whole
bunch of truckloads of dynamite
and then send you out and ask you to
build a pyramid
and you find out that the only way you
could get it was just by randomly
throwing dynamite around and after a
long enough period of time you ended up
with a pyramid
i'm going to say the problem isn't your
algorithm choice it's the tool set
dynamite is not the right tool to build
a pyramid
and pip reader is not the right tool to
create portraits
it's possible that we haven't discovered
something amazing on pic breeder yet
which could revolutionize
um the way that we do portraits but
anyway just in closing so we can't spend
too much time on this but
he also um cites the finnish education
system they have this concept which
imposes no standardization on tests or
students at all in fact
the system follows the spirit of
non-objective search and it's a world
leader in education of course
it's this idea of creativity certainly
i've read a couple of papers on this
where people say oh
kids are actually very creative and
school conformalizes them and almost
kills the creativity in our kids um so
he says that the lesson is that
silencing
diversity is a surefire way to slow down
progress and uh we're going to be saying
the silence
silence diversity though so here's his
black and white his entire book is so
black and white right it's all a bunch
of false dilemmas
nobody's saying to silence diversity
people are saying that a combination
of let's call it novelty search plus
objective optimization is the way to go
that it isn't binary black white do one
or the other and he
constantly poses these false dilemmas
just
i had a hard time reading the book
because there was just faulty actual
logic throughout the entire book i just
just
it was just a false dilemma logical
fallacy
one after another after another until
finally you're left just
oh i guess i believe what he says
because i've completely become
unta untethered from any logic
interesting okay that's just me i'm just
some guy
i think i think we're all on board
though the mixed approach is necessary
it's just how we respond to the actual
arguments made that we differ in our
viewpoints
i think this is actually a wonderful
metaphor for so many
future conversations that we'll have so
we'll come back to that
but anyway we've got about 50 minutes
left and we need to talk about capsule
networks
god knows we need to talk about it
because keith and i earlier on were
talking about
affine transformations we said wouldn't
it be wonderful if we had a computer
vision algorithm
that would be invariant to various
different types of affine
transformations and then some smart alec
came on our
youtube comments and said oh that
already exists
it's called capsule networks have you
have you not looked at it yet so
we have actually looked at it today
we've been looking at it in some detail
and i suppose
one of the starting concepts i want to
talk about is this notion
of equivariance and invariance because i
hear this jargon mounted about
quite a lot and the the difference is
right so i've got a little
thing here for feature maps in
convolution on your networks to be
useful
they typically need both properties in
some balance right
as in in variance and equivariance the
equivariance allows the network to
generalize
edge texture shape detection in
different locations
and the invariance allows precise
locations of the detected features to
matter less
these two are complementary types of
generalization for many image processing
tasks right so
equivariance to translation means that a
translation of input features
results in an equivalent translation of
the output so if you
have a pattern in this part of the input
space and then you then change the input
to move you expect the response map to
change with it so a
convolutional neural network layer is
equivariant
invariants to translation means that the
translation of input features does not
change the outputs at all
and that's what a convolution on your
network as a whole does because you
actually don't want it to be equivalent
you
you want regardless of where the dog is
on the input space you want it to say
dog you don't want to say oh it's a dog
but with a caveat
yeah so i think you could just say
equivariance is a generalization of
invariance so
invariance is equivariance where the
only transform you allow
is the identity transformation so you're
just saying that the output is
identical to to what whereas
equivariance it can be whatever a linear
just some type of known transformation
in the output
yeah so we started going through the
capsule now it's big
shout out to the youtube comments source
of all the system in the world
but as we went into them we started
discovering that perhaps they're not
invariant or equivariant as
as it as has been claimed
there's certainly they start to there's
a lot of talk that they can exploit
these sorts of
affine transforms these sorts of
rotational symmetries
that do exist in native photos but
that's just
bollocks it's a load of words on a page
and nothing mechanically actually
resembles that
yeah so to put a maybe a more charitable
spin on it and by the way i
i found this jonathan hui has this
really cool blog post about uh
capsule networks that and the positive
spin i take on is
the goal of capsule networks to have
this transformation matrix that operate
on a pose
you know let's just say uh standardized
initialize the pose into an output
that's all great if it's exactly what i
had in mind with this afine and variant
sort of transformations i think
the issue is that it's like that's what
a capsule should do
and a capsule network is a bunch of
these capsules together but when you get
into the details of how to actually
build that capsule
it's where it becomes much more
difficult it's like yeah we we can
we sort of got it to be fine invariant
for
some kind of pieces of that or within
some range
but not at all scales or this type of
thing like here i'll give you like a
simple example
let's suppose that we have a capsule
that recognizes houses
okay because at some lower level there's
some other capsules that recognize
windows doors roof etc if
and suppose that house is centered in my
frame of view
right if i rotate that house
around the center of the picture okay
the there's going to be different
rotations depending on the radius that
you are
out from that center for all these
components a door
that's near the center will have a
transformation matrix a pose
very similar to the house itself but
let's say on the
outside like on the outer corner a
window is going to have a pose that's
very different
from the pose of the door the pose of
the house as a whole
and it's not clear to me like what the
math is behind all those combinations of
poses like
how do we handle larger scale rotations
it seems like an interesting direction
to pursue
i think there's a lot of detail that i
just don't know but maybe it's out there
and we need to do or i need to do a lot
more homework
uh or maybe it's just it's still a
difficult problem and it's not quite
solved yet i don't know
so when i first had a glance at the
capsule networks wikipedia page
i thought it was doing something super
clever like that oh it has some kind of
pose matrix and it's cleverly looking at
loads of different
i find transformations and poses it's
not
i can share yannick's video obviously
yannick lightspeed culture he's made a
video about absolutely bloody everything
including capsule networks
and we should i'm going to give you this
link if you don't have it already to
jonathan whee's blog post because it's a
great
kind of explanation of it uh we should
put it in the youtube
description too yeah sure he's got one
on both
the the dynamic routing and the em
matrix version of capsules okay we'll
come to that in in a second then so
let's just
quickly um skip through this so the way
yannick explains this is that capsule
networks it's
now first of all cnns already do this
cnns learn features as part of the
training process in a hierarchy
and you can't define what those features
are a priority they just learn from the
data
so they can be anything so when we talk
about these capsules as being features
we're talking hypothetically
because it's probably not going to
correspond to those features
okay so can i just jump in real quickly
here
the like uh front runner a heap of the
things that are going to come up
the problem is that these things are
defined on vector spaces
just general vector spaces as opposed to
on manifolds
because like poses transform very simply
they're they're really quite simple
objects
um up to a scale factor that was your
how do things operate at different scale
they're undefined up to a scale
but like up to that point they're very
well understood objects
it's just when the capsule networks are
saying oh
we're estimating these quantities no
you've got a 4x4 matrix under there
whose elements are you know being
optimized independently of one another
they're not transforming according to
some underlying algebra
a lot of the problems are just coming
from that right like the
they're not aware now there are all of
the algebra
cnns that live out there that the
various ones that optimize over a
manifold
they're doing some really cool work with
capsule nets that are bringing it closer
like much
i guess what we're criticizing here is
the overreaching claims of the original
research
it's not the idea is bad but the idea is
actually really clever
it's just it's not there yet i i totally
agree with you and i think it's a very
promising
direction and like i said i don't know
enough about it yet to say anything
other than
seems like a great path to pursue seems
like there's a lot of work left to do
would love to see more people interested
in it and
and putting resource and thought into it
because uh like it is explained on that
blog post does a good job of explaining
the exact problem i brought up many
times with cnns
is that we're wasting parameter space
learning things like a face at zero
degree orientation a face at 20 degrees
orientation
and that's all kind of hacked and kludgy
anyway it's not going to capture the
true invariance
of rotation and so if we just build that
in however where it's done capsule
network yes
but they don't that's the thing yeah
well they may not now
but they're they're thinking about it in
a very i think it's a very clear way to
think about it
at least it's just maybe it's not there
in an implementation yet
i i think it's not and i'll explain why
so at the moment
we we have these input capsules and
yannick has said they might
learn this kind of semantic information
so wool roof
door and lake and so on and then of
course these
the main difference with these as
compared to
cnns is these actually produce a vector
of output
and this vector space here and this is a
two dimensional vector space so this is
notionally angle and color and
the magnitude of this vector first of
all it's normalized
so that it's got length one so one means
that the probability is very high
so if it's one it means i really think
that this roof
is here but you can then use the
direction in the other
dimensions to ascertain things like the
angle and the color but you don't know
what these things are these are just
learned because these capsule networks
are framed up as a way of giving you
let's say affine invariants but that's
not the case at all you still need to
give it
examples of your object being rotated in
every possible way
which means it's still wasting the
representational capacity of the cnn
encoder exactly the same as it was
before
the encoder here every single capsule
here is a planar cnn
and it has all of the failings of planar
cnns okay so that's the part i wasn't
clear on
yet because i hadn't studied enough was
i wasn't sure
if that that uh transformation matrix
was something that would that was being
estimated like
when it does a a prediction i wasn't
sure if that was being estimated on the
fly
and then just essentially marginalized
out i
just do the maximum likelihood
estimation of that matrix apply it then
you get this output vector which goes on
further into the network
because if it was doing that then that
would buy you
like true affine and variance at least
for all the data that was coming into
that node
or not quite affirming variance but best
estimation affine variants but what
you're
saying is it's developing some type of
fixed
transformation matrix based on the input
samples or something
to fill in some gaps just there may be
some people out there that are a bit
blank on details anyway what you're
doing with
each of these capsules is you're taking
a single input feature like a single
output a single channel from another cnn
and then you're within the the within
the unit itself you're notionally
corresponding the pose of an input to
the
pose of the notion reflected by the node
so
the relationship the spatial
relationship between the walls
the door and the roof of the house to
the idea of the house
right you're not going to find the roof
on the bottom unless the picture is
upside down in which case the door will
be upside down as well
and so this idea of exploiting the the
geometric ordering of objects to build
up these
latent representations of objects is
basically what's going on here
that's why the thing is it's not
explicitly
looking at the spatial relationship
although that's a likely side effect of
the algorithm depending on how you
trained it because these dimensions on
the vector could correspond to anything
it doesn't necessarily mean the spatial
dimension but the way that this has been
pitched though
by uh hinton is that at the moment
convolution on your networks they have
this
inductive prior which
it it it only recognizes spatial
information locally the whole idea of
cnns is to reduce the number of
parameters in the network we just have
these tiny filters that we
shine over the larger image and that
gives us this translational equivariance
but it also means that we cannot learn
long-term spatial dependencies in the
image so you get all of these really
weird things happening
now we can learn long-term spatial
relationships in the image
but it's a bit different because in the
convolution on your network you have max
pooling layers and then
eventually you have a densely connected
network at the end and that can actually
learn global relationships between
things
but not in a spatial relation only if
they both exist
but remember for a good cnn image
classifier we don't actually want it to
be equivalent we want it to be
invariant at the end we just want to
know is there an eye and is there a nose
in the image
but then you get the picasso problem
because it no longer learns the correct
spatial relation between the eye and the
nose
yeah more and more people aren't so much
interested in just an invariant label
more and more people want pixel wise
labels and so that loss of
spatial information becomes a real
problem and you end up using all these
engineering hacks to get around that
to get around something that perhaps if
cnns were designed a little better
would be information that was preserved
and exploited
that's one thing i thought was pretty
cool about the capsule
network at least formulation and i again
i have to keep prefacing this by saying
i have a lot more homework to do
okay audience out there take this for
what it's worth but what i thought was
cool about
is it had this notion of a pose and that
if you could track that
transformation matrix and you could
track the uh it wasn't called voting it
was called something else for kind of
each feature was load on the pose for
the combined
capsule at the higher layer and whatnot
and so you can keep track of all that
and then just reverse the projections
back down do interesting things with
with the the original pixels like you
were saying yeah look
maybe maybe if we do enough homework
maybe we could convince uh
dr hinton to come on here and i think we
can educate us and answer some questions
for us because
i personally find it a pretty
interesting intellectual
framework to think about it i just don't
know enough about how far it's actually
made it
in implementation it hasn't made it very
far
and even because the first thing is that
the first paper i think was
what was the name of the paper can
someone help me out here i think it was
this one yeah stacked
capsule auto encoders and this was
actually in about 2011
and the co-author i think was krachevsky
oh no have i have i just hallucinated
that i'm sure krachevsky
maybe this is another paper i was
reading i'm fairly sure it's alex
krachewski who's you know the guy who
won the imagenet competition in 2012.
but anyway the key thing though is that
they first published this long before
the the vision and cnn revolution that
we've had in the last eight years or so
okay so coming in you know but that
could be maybe that's the hardware
lottery and or the attention lottery i
think in addition to a hardware lottery
we have attention lotteries
if everyone most the population is doing
work on
a certain line of research it may just
take a while for another to catch up
yeah and credit where credit's due this
is an attempt to rethink
something that's fairly fundamental to
how computer vision's done these days
there are a lot of shades in this paper
that are kind of coming up again i can't
remember the name axial attention and
deep lab
i i started reading through these papers
and i started seeing this connection
between
what's going on here and what they're
trying to do with these
pure attention-driven alternatives to
cnns
and at some point i'm going to find some
time and sit down and look into that a
little bit
deeper but the the idea is good the idea
is good it's just
when you dig into the actual
implementation it's
a bit all over the shop and it's also
they're trying to hard solve problems
even with that the paper we talked about
with the circular harmonics
for some degree of rotation and variance
at least at certain scales
if you start to try to think about okay
how would i do that at all scales
yeah it starts to become quite difficult
but it's quite interesting because all
of that stuff by um
mostly cohen and welling they were
inspired by
hinton oh really oh yeah so all of that
stuff came from capsule networks but but
i think
hinton was solving a completely
different problem because they were
directly trying to place inductive
priors into the cnn models to make them
equivalent
and i don't really see that in hinton's
architecture this is more about
learning the relationships between a
hierarchy of things
but in a much richer semantic way let's
just
spend a little bit more time just
quickly talking through
this algorithm can i point out something
about that though i agree there's a lot
of work
on that height let's say the first layer
of capsules and above
is what you're talking about there like
that the hierarchy of semantic kind of
combinations and whatnot
but the other half of it is what makes
up a capsule
and so inside there where you have this
pose and the transformation matrix
you can see the circular harmonics is a
different way of thinking about that
in addition or maybe an augmentation to
that maybe we still have the pose and
the transformation matrix and in
addition
we have some circular harmonics and like
for example
maybe we would have even rgb stuff in
there like we're going to do a
transformation to scilab
color space and do things like only care
about the luminance and forget about a
and b
or because we know that we're going to
be you doing the recognition in low
light conditions and highlight
conditions or
infrared or whatever so i think it could
be seen as an
extension to that but the fact that they
were at least partly inspired
by this work i think does point to there
being value in this way of thinking
about it
even if it leads to inspiration for
other developments
yeah absolutely and it's undoubtable
that capsule networks will be more
sample efficient but because of this
routing algorithm they're painfully slow
let's let's super quick it's a trade-off
isn't it always isn't it
so here's a super quick example of how
this works so you have an input image
and this is uh the classic mnist
and lo and behold we're still using
planar
2d cnns to do the encoding and
on this particular one that they've got
an output volume with a depth of 256 so
i've got a whole bunch of uh different
filters that they're learning and the
idea is that
this output volume is going to be split
up into what are called capsules
so we're still maintaining this kind of
spatial domain
and this is a spatial domain of capsules
that we are learning different features
and
with some mathematical tricks we can
actually just maintain this in in one
huge matrix but yannick goes on
can i wait can i ask a question about
that and i'm hoping the two of you can
educate me here
i could almost envision that each of
these primary capsules for example could
be completely independently trained
neural networks like i'm going to go and
create a data sample
of just roofs and train it to recognize
roofs and then i'm going to reuse that
as a capsule like a fixed component of a
neural network
i'm just curious like how much work out
there is being done at the moment with
in independently training subpieces of a
larger neural
network can you tell me it's transfer
learning the beauty of deep learning is
the compositionality
well the transfer learning though is i
think transfer learning as i've
often seen it is more on the on an
entire network at a time
and then i'm just talking about training
and training a network that recognizes
only roofs only doors only this and then
combining those
as just essentially neurons within a
network are people doing that
is that i haven't seen anything i i had
a quick
deep dive into this space this afternoon
and i didn't see anything like that but
i could definitely see
something like that being worth a shot
it would lead to some
it would definitely lead to some
weirdness and some weird overfitting
problems on
particular data sets add to the fact
that capsule nets
don't deal too well with multiple
instantiations of the same object and
you're going to start running into
problems fairly fast
but you know as a line of future
research imagine a cnn are we believe
the following
features are important throw them in
from the standardized library
just one line of code and download the
pre-trained filters for whatever
class of object you expect and bring
your data requirements down to
zero that would be amazing you don't
typically see that though so at the
moment we have this beautiful
flexibility and deep learning where you
can compose together different networks
that have been pre-trained
but usually it's for different domains
so you'd have a language processing
encoder or a vision encoder or even
speech recognition and the reason why
you tend to have monolithic networks
across large domains is precisely
because
the networks are so good at reusing
concepts and
sharing um sub features in a hierarchy
just like gbt3 for example it's got no
problem at all eating up
the entire internet and creating this
beautiful hierarchy of shared concepts
across there so it would be a complete
waste
of a neural network to train one for
dogs and one for cats you might as well
just
throw it all in there together and it
will structure it in this incredible way
yeah i i hear you about the that the
entanglement
if you will the entanglement between the
different parts of the network buys you
some
compression some efficiency um
i'm not a hundred percent sure that it
that we wouldn't gain
something else like these invariant and
variants or maybe even
for example maybe you could use much
simpler networks to recognize
just these sub components and then
combine them so even though
we wouldn't gain from the entanglement
reuse and compression
we could actually gain by having much
simpler or smaller parameter spaces and
then maybe they'd be
more parsimonious i don't know i just
curious how much work out there was
being done
and combining independently trained
networks into larger networks and you've
got to admit the idea of like
compositionality here it's an elegant
one it's a really nice one that kind of
appeals to the human idea of like
what intelligence could do and what it
could be and this the space of
possibility that it opens up is pretty
amazing but yeah i
as far as i've seen it there's nothing
in that that space at the moment
okay all right so if i have to go back
to school that would be a
good research paradigm to follow them
potentially i wouldn't listen to my
advice on
what research paradigm to follow i'm
more of a
stepping stone skipper myself yeah
well yeah skipper novelty treasure
hunting
but anyway clearly what we need to do
here is learn a whole bunch of weight
matrices and this is
standard neural network stuff to
transform the output all of these
vectors so we we
normalize them as we said and then we
want to transform them into these
outputs
and this is where this clever routing
algorithm thing comes in and
again we need to have a way of
transforming these now what we already
do is we learn
a bunch of transformation matrices right
weight matrices to transform
from these blocks into these rows over
here and
this is where this routing algorithm
comes in right so the way that yannick
sketched it
is rather than just doing this in one
step
and then eventually it goes over here
and also
there's a relationship between the two
layers because you need to know what the
output of the next capsule is
because essentially this is looking at
correspondence it's saying
i want to learn the correspondence to
maximally map the outputs of the
capsules on the left to the outputs on
the right
and turns out actually this is very
similar to the way transformers work
but transformers don't work in this kind
of weird feature space they work on
tokens but
the routing algorithm with the queries
and the keys and so on is all about
seeing
from the perspective of this word which
words coming in correspond to me
and this is saying from the perspective
of the house which one looks like a roof
right so what this is doing is it's
looking
it's learning a kind of a tension vector
on all of these capsules so it knows
which
in capsules should i pay attention to so
it's not just the weight matrices it's
also learning this attention thing
and would you like to
give us some elevated picture on this
alex oh
no i really don't i i think this idea is
insane
the there is a bit of secret sauce that
goes into this
the attention that is learned for the
mapping between i and j
on our screen here depends on the output
of j
it's like a cosine similarity between
the transition matrix between i and j
and the output of j itself
so you have to first calculate w i j
and then get uh organic call i think he
called it oj
at the oh yeah we can do that we can go
forward a bit there we go beautiful
so we've got it for this capsule we've
got all of the
so we've got all of the capsules coming
in so we have
a quadratic number of weight matrices
and for this capsule coming in we've got
all the weight matrices for all of the
other n capsules
and then we can multiply we can take the
scalar product
and we get this oj and then we check the
inner product between
oj and every single one of those outputs
to decide
which ones mattered for the overall
pose of the concept and then use that
we go back and we re-weight our inputs
based on that exactly and iteratively
also all of these dot products they'll
be high if there's a high correspondence
but then we update this attention thing
and then we rinse and repeat a few times
and then eventually only the ones that
and then i think we'd
take a soft max at some point but yeah
eventually only
the capsules that have a high
correspondence in coming into this
capsule
will be weighted on that attention
vector
and that that's basically this is that's
almost an attempt it's almost an attempt
to
to obtain a sparse solution like
but via expectation maximization
during optimization and like it's an
inner optimization loop
inside your optimization loop that you
even have to do it test time
it's bonkers like why can't this be done
end to end
surely there is a way to do this end to
end
yeah it has to be done at test time as
well yeah
okay yeah i got i have a lot more
homework to do with capital networks
sorry does it have to be i didn't think
it had to be done at tesla it has to be
done at test time
what this routing thing but we already
but we've already learned the
yeah the weight matrix yeah but we're
not updating the weights we're updating
the attention and that's done using em
on every forward pass
that's why i was checking the code
earlier just because i i read this i'm
like
surely they're not doing this and sure
enough they're doing it
wow there you go but i i wanted to show
because the way they compute the loss on
this when you actually
update the the gradients is they also
use this reconstructed loss as well so
they've changed the architecture to use
a
densely connected neural network to re
create the input image and then they
have a reconstructive loss
but they multiply that by about 0.05 or
something
and then they use they use a loss
against the actual
learned features don't they
the loss they're using is just it's a
fairly simple contrastive loss
if you've ever played around with
self-supervised stuff it looks like
triple loss only
yeah margin loss but in a contrastive
format against the
negative classes yeah this guy
and they want to make it between 0.1 and
0.9
and presumably that's so that they can
use it in conjunction with the
reconstructed loss yeah so this guy
so this is the margin loss the thought
behind using the reconstruction loss is
really clever
that's taking the idea of the inverse
computer graphics and just running with
it
we've got this boiled down
representation of an object and its pose
and theoretically that should be enough
to reconstruct and
render that object and then do some you
know loss function with it
the problem is of course that minor
changes in that sort of pose space like
this is why all these pose invariant
networks oppose proposed right
minor changes in that pose matrix space
lead to
huge changes in the the projection onto
the pixel matrix
or the pixel space right so even though
it is this beautiful elegant idea that
in theory is is wonderful you like a
real proof of concept of this idea of
encapsulating
objects within the matrix in practice
it's almost got
no and no way of practically working but
it'll give you a vague fuzzy blob
on the screen where an object should be
and if you're lucky it may
resemble the pose but yeah for anything
more than eminence that's a
shot in the dark this thing's quite
interesting so
on this one it's actually showing so
it's it did the lpr right which is the
label
predicted and the reconstructed and when
there's not a correspondence so when
they predicted the wrong thing you can
see some interesting points of confusion
so here for example the label was a five
and it predicted a three and you can see
that the reconstructed output
shows something that looks very confused
between a three and a five
yep and another thing that they show in
the paper
is because the whole point of this is
about
learning various different types of
transformations or semantically
equivalent transformations and i think
it's been
understood by many to mean things like
rotation and variance and stuff like
that but it's not
i think this shows quite clearly because
what they've done here is on the
reconstructed
because essentially this is a bit like
an auto encoder so you you can
across these um capsule dimensions you
can reconstruct different variations of
the
image and these are showing that what
the type of transformations look like
and it's stuff like strike thickness
localized skew so you can see on this
one across the domain of
of this capsule dimension you can see
the four is becoming more
skewed as you'll notice there's no
rotation
going on here and why would there be
because mnist doesn't have any rotations
so what it's doing is it's learning
dimensions of difference that are
semantically relevant to the data that
it sees yeah so those last like the
fours and
in particular so the localized skew in
time
series analysis for example there's a
thing called dynamic time warping
so the idea is that on the time axis you
can as long as you're doing
transformations that don't result in
any cuts to the timeline so you're just
compressing certain areas or
warping and whatnot spreading making
thinner
that there's a lot of time series that
actually have that structure
like for one reason or another the flow
of time for whatever process it is that
you're observing
isn't uniform with calendar time like
stock market for example
that there can be periods of very high
volatility taking place within a few
minutes after
some announcement and so you
operationally get a lot more time
within that piece of calendar time than
you did for all the morning
before the announcement or whatnot and
similar types of things occur
as well and and just our in image you
know capture for example you have a
drop of water on the lens and it results
in the
continuous warping of that little piece
there so far we've mostly been talking
about affine invariants and our kind of
transformation
discussions because i was just trying to
focus on a simple one
that to get everybody convinced that
they should try to work that into their
neural network
kind of paradigms but all these other
kinds of transformations
are also very real and useful so
interesting that the capsule networks
were
finding some of those um well i think
i'm being a little bit unfair because
first of all it's really interesting
what you say about the dynamic time
warping because
as you say there are lots of interesting
sequence alignment problems
that that you get a with time series but
in this particular case capsule networks
could learn
a rotational fine transformation if you
gave it data and the key thing is that
it would then become one of these
capsule dimensions and you could then
commute across those those
transformations so
it would learn it as a first-class
citizen but the key thing is because of
that planar
convolutional encoder it would waste a
shitload of representational capacity to
learn
all of those different versions coming
in yeah that's the part that i wasn't so
clear on how that was because i haven't
done enough homework how that was
being handled and maybe it's not being
handled it sounds like again it sounds
like there's a lot of work to be done
but i think it's a good kind of initial
framework to
ponder these deeper questions it is
worth noting we're talking about
vectors here and vectors are much
simpler to discuss the concept because
we can use like
uh the extension that i'm about to talk
about has a lot of engineering hacks
baked into it to make it work with
matrices but they recognize that hey
we can't actually capture um 3d
transformations
or like rigid trans transformations with
eight
an eight element vector i think how many
degrees of freedom is there
in a 3d rotation and translation like
15 i think there's 15. so they
instead said hey let's actually start
thinking about this in terms of these
pose matrices and so they built a
follow-up paper to this
adds an extra dimension to your feature
maps and all of a sudden you're working
with
pose matrices of various objects
now whether or not whether or not
they're actually doing that
i'm very much of the opinion that
they're probably not although there have
been papers released that have
tried to explicitly encode this
information but they're definitely
thinking through these problems
and trying to make it more reflect this
kind of quest for
an object-wise invariance like it's
there
having dismissed the concept very early
on i i should be a little even-handed
and say
there are some very good ideas there and
they are developing in this direction
that you expressed but yeah they're just
not they're
there quite yet yeah and so
to the degrees of freedom i'm virtually
certain everything can fit within a four
by four
matrix and i don't think you don't need
all 16 elements so it's down to
3d transformations affine transfer
transformations or
11 or 12 or something degrees of freedom
and i think in that four by four matrix
you may even be able to work in a couple
other transformations
yeah but yeah i second what you're
saying which is
i think it's a a good framework to start
with and there's probably just
a lot of work that hasn't been done and
you tim like you said a couple times the
implementation is probably
hasn't come a long way yet but i'd love
to see a lot more work into it honestly
i think we need both though because
remember in the real world there is a
kind of
topological relationship between objects
and that's super important and i think
capsule networks are going a long way in
that direction i think
we shouldn't confuse that with the
direction that
cohen and weldon have gone in i mean
this is a set of slides i think
from max welling and the idea is that
first of all it depends on the data
domain so are you on a manifold are you
on a graph
um are you in a geometric space and
there'll be all sorts of objects in
those
substrates that you could do
what i would call a semantically
equivalent transformation
so think of a graph for example you
could represent the same graph
in a completely different way in that
adjacency matrix and
your graph cnn will just think that's a
completely new graph
so even when you're modeling graphs you
need to have permutation equivariance
and what we're really driving towards
here is really clever inductive priors
that mean we don't need to have such a
huge representational capacity to
basically record many
similacrums of the same thing sure and
another interesting thing to keep in
mind too is that
and this is what's cool about the
capsule networks is that since they are
recording if you will
at some point the transformations and
there's the potential to have them
propagate around and whatnot
what's really useful about that is
sometimes you actually do care
about like for example if i'm trying to
distinguish between an
airplane versus a model airplane
i don't want scale invariants because
the scale information
is an important piece of that criteria
maybe i need some type of yardstick or
whatever
to normalize it but i need to know what
that scale is i don't want
a network that actually it's fine if a
part of the network is
invariant or equivariant to that but i
need to have access to that
information so that i can have another
node that's telling me whether or not
it's actually maybe a model airplane and
not or a drone
instead of a human piloted airplane that
sort of thing
one one teensy tiny problem that like
this is a really good point but
i think most of these transforms are
only defined up to
a scale like generally you normalize the
transformation matrix to have the
bottom right entry equal one which is
you yeah it's your scale factor
would it like how would you even
represent that and then still have it
live on these manifold of
valid geometric transformations just
relax that constraint
don't force w or whatever that component
is is to be
one allow it to you reckon it'd be that
simple
simple for what purpose i don't know but
yeah that was
that wasn't this asia is like genuinely
because you can always choose to
renormalize
so if you've got w something else
besides one and if
it and again we're talking about like in
the context of neural networks so who
knows what they're gonna choose to do
but my point
is in theory they could choose to always
normalize
back to one so a group of nodes could
decide that they're ignoring
the scale for their purpose but another
group of nodes
could decide that that is important for
classifying whether this is a model
airplane or whatnot so
i just think it's cool that capsule
networks maybe have built in the idea
that
this is information that needs to be
explicitly
available or tracked and not just
disappearing into the kind of mesh if
you will
yeah so we've got seven minutes what are
we gonna talk about now tim
what can we talk about in seven minutes
that something controversial maybe
we could take some more pot shots that
are hinting no
no no no that'll take care of you come
on later
let's learn more and ask them to come
set us right
and tell us uh tell us you know
because do you think that he's uh not
going to be sending us any christmas
cards this year
i uh look i mean like hey look i admit i
i don't know nearly enough to pass and
again i've only said that
we don't either which this is a
promising a promising kind of
intellectual framework it just seems
there needs to be a lot more work done
on it and it's like this this attention
lottery
and hardware lottery let's try to roll
that again
get some more attention on this it is
funny though how we see
concepts just coming up time and time
again because it's very closely related
i think to the
the attention is all you need and yeah
because we only really looked at this
today and we we've recognized quite a
lot of concept then i'll be the first to
admit that
we may well have misunderstood some of
the things here but
it has been really interesting learning
about this yeah one
one thing that kind of i'm increasingly
noticing i've spent a lot of time
thinking about making algorithms faster
lately and
how to accelerate algorithms that that
are
just considered too slow to use but just
really haven't had the time put into
them
and this was a really good example today
like a lot of the implementations of
this idea
involve hacking around pre-built
tensorflow components
and to an extent like having these
components accessible
is great it's massively accelerated
research for the entire community
it allows everyone to get their feet wet
but like the the kinds of people who
used to work in cafe the times the types
of people that used to just
code in pure c or c plus
it's taught in all the universities over
here because it's a secret weapon that's
why
it's awesome i love it i'm coming around
to it like i've been starting to program
in it because
there are a lot of things that that are
really slow until you
just get your hands dirty go out and
build a proper computer kernel and then
put the python bindings in all of a
sudden it's lightning fast
and so these capsule networks i'm
laughing earlier about it's got a loop
within a loop
how there's no new information going
into that how
much slower would this be if instead of
doing it the way that it's done
in terms of these matrix multiplications
constantly handing
the data back and forth between the gpu
if you would just build a dedicated
kernel
hand the data across once do the entire
optimization then hand it back to python
maybe this wouldn't seem like such a
ridiculous clunky process maybe it's
just
we're all as researchers as
practitioners we've all gotten a bit
lazy and a bit coddled
uh with the the fantastic libraries that
we have
well even then we've been reading uh
sarah hooker's
hardware lottery and the thesis on on
that
is that she argues it was hugely
serendipitous that the deep learning
revolution happened because we just
happened to have these gpus
that were optimized for people to play
games on their machines and then
obviously
alex krachevsky or whoever it was used
cuda and won the imagenet competition as
a result
and apparently the generalist concept of
cpus was because
in the early days when they built a
specialist cpu to do something
it would be superseded the next year by
the generalist cpu
yep yeah now that moore's law is it
slowed down at least it it's
it seems like it has to me in terms of
the growth of processor speeds and
whatnot
now we're starting to consider much more
dedicated hardware whether it's in the
form of
fpgas though that are programmable to be
dedicated if you will or for certain
classes of problems
they're very profitable let's say
bitcoin mining let's get some asics
dedicated for that
yeah so on that because that's actually
super interesting cause i know
microsoft released project brainwave a
couple of years ago which is their a6
and then we've got google's tpus
intel have just people keep talking
about neuromorphic chips and i thought
god is that something that i just don't
know about
am i missing a trick here tesla's
running them in their vehicles at the
moment like dedicated
new uh neural network oh architected
chipsets for like massively accelerated
computation
chips built like neural networks no i
don't that's the way it was framed to me
people said oh um
this is some amazing revolution in ai
we've got the chips that are
that they're just like human brains but
on a chip but that's not true at all is
it i'm not a hardware guy i
i used to work with a guy who was a
hardware guy who had his hands on some
of these
cutting edge neuromorphic neuromorphic
gpus
but they were really just they were
optimized for
neural networks rather than general
restricted instruction set computations
and
so a lot of what i'm reading about
neuromorphic computing
falls into two categories the actual
neurobiology inspired stuff that sort of
research space and then there's the
stuff
that's out there in industry at the
moment which
just seems to be more like purpose built
for
the deep learning paradigm the latter
form
you see a lot more but there is like
explicit neuromorphic stuff that
is cool in terms of how they mimic
biological processes at the transistor
level i'm just a little bit worried
about this because whenever people talk
about deep learning especially if
they're selling it
they anthropomorphize it and
all of the kind of chips specialize for
running neural network models in my
experience that kind of fpga type things
and is it just that
well whatever it is if i could convince
our listeners of one thing
there are no silver bullets okay like
end of story i can't so i used to
work mainly in biomedical uh research or
bioengineering and
it seemed every month there was a quote
cure for cancer
right well the first thing is cancer is
a whole
population and spectrum of diseases like
there are some cancers that are very
treatable
some that are not treatable at all and a
lot of this is just the sort of normal
hype cycle that
people always go through new cure for
cancer this month it's the same thing
here right like people are trying to
hype up
whatever it is that they're working on
and present it as the next greatest
sort of silver bullet there is there are
no silver bullets folks
there will always be fundamental
trade-offs
between time space energy
etc and there's no magic chip that's
going to come
somehow elevate us out of that okay like
quantum computing there's all these
misconceptions about quantum computing
okay like you took the words out of my
mouth yeah
quantum computing look we understand the
theory
of quantum computing quite well we can't
build chips that well for qualm
computing but we understand the theory
and that's kind of computational theory
of computation
those folks understand the complexity
class
of quantum computing that it can solve
in linear time it's qp
i think qp or whatever and there's qp
complete problems and whatnot
i got bad news for you that's not a very
big space
of problems in the space of all problems
okay so
quantum computing is not suddenly going
to just we're not going to solve global
warming with it
okay it can do some things much better
than
classical computers but only a small
sliver of things
in the space of all types of
computational problems
it is interesting though on more than
one occasion i've found myself
looking for hypothetical probability
distributions that don't exist and it's
you're faced with the choice of do you
use a gaussian copula
or do you go looking for the the right
thing
and every time i've encountered one of
those problems
it's turned out i've required some kind
of quantum system to
get the the actual probability
distribution
and it at first i thought quantum
computing it's this
absolute bs term that people are just
using to sell hardware
google's using it to promote themselves
but
the um it's even though yes
there's shaw's algorithm and what else
like nothing
but it still comes up in very
interesting
and unusual places like estimating
estimating
the co-occurrence of methylation
on dna let's see that's right that's
because of the domain that you're
working in
so when you're working on modeling
physical systems
which are quantum it shouldn't be
surprising that the problems you need to
solve
might map well to quantum computing
it's just the gain covariance into
discrete systems like
continuous covariance into discrete
systems is
difficult and so usually you hack around
it but if you want an actual
correlated discrete random variable you
find yourself wandering into quantum
space very quickly
sure yeah so there are a lot of natural
things that arise that map all that
space i'm only pointing out that
the complexity class qp oh yeah for
those out there go look it up sometime
what the qp complexity class is and how
it fits in the venn diagram
of all sort of computational classes and
you'll be a little less
silver bullet enthusiastic about what
quantum computing is going to do for the
world
i will say i know a professor at the
university of queensland her name name's
sally shrapnel
she is without a shadow of a doubt one
of the most
accomplished people i've ever met like
seriously started at i think it was
king's college doing philosophy
casually over a couple of years did a
medical degree
got married raising kids went back to
uni doing a phd on quantum causality
and then is now working quantum
artificial intelligence overachievers
but like she's so awesome she has some
really interesting things to say about
this quantum computing malarkey she'll
point out that until are
stable cubits it's a myth it's all
hypothetical
you can't do anything useful until
they're stable
and then you need error correcting codes
which interferes with your computations
that being said she does stuff like
simulates neural networks using like ion
traps and stuff like that
and the neat thing about how that kind
of works is that it
automatically optimizes because it's
just an energy function that
gets minimized and so like there is some
cool stuff there
yeah it's not all marketing height but
yeah marketing hype yeah and for example
we've talked a couple of times about
touring turing machines and completing
so it's a natural question to wonder
is there anything more powerful than a
turing machine
and is there something that can do hyper
computation
and if you will one example of such a
theoretical machine is called
a real computer and it's an idealization
of an analog computer
so it's basically a computer that has
these real
functions can perform these real
functions on real variables to
arbitrary precision infinite precision
or whatever
in polynomial time and if you just have
that then you have forms of computation
that are hyper computation but can we
ever
actually get to that i think there's a
lot of good evidence that the answer is
no that we're forever going to be stuck
with essentially
what at the end of the day a turing
machine could do in an infinite amount
of time
or a uh not an infinite amount of time
potentially
a potentially infinite amount of times
rather than actually having run for an
infinite amount of time so we're just
stuck in this there is no hyper
computation that's one
possible answer for the universe if you
will
awesome gentlemen to infinity and beyond
it's been a fantastic conversation today
and what i'll say yeah for folks that
have made it this far
if you would like to suggest something
for us to talk about
maybe come and join us on the star trek
enterprise or
give us a philosophical topic a topic to
discuss then we'll do that
that's a cool idea like we could pose uh
maybe we can do a little straw poll too
once we get some topic ideas put up a
straw poll see what people want us to
talk about
and uh within reason i think we're gonna
need to come back around for these uh
these algebra that the group cnns
take a closer look at them and see where
they're leading because the capsule nets
didn't get us there but we know where
the next step is
about let's talk more about bayesian too
marginalization
model selection probability theory is
logic those would be fun topics
oh let's just bust out the probability
textbooks
let's do some fundamental proofs let's
do it on a whiteboard
today we actually can still do math or
at least mathematica we'll do some live
mathematica
i was so embarrassed after our
conversation last week
i immediately bought uh bayesian data
analysis three
and then keith said to me tim what are
you doing man
you need to go and buy sylvia so i did i
bought data
sevier sorry sylvia so i bought data
analysis a bayesian tutorial
and i've already started reading it
actually and it's it's super interesting
i'm going to be completely converted to
bayesian
i recommend that book that data analysis
of bayesian tutorial
i think uh model selection is early on
it's like chapter two or three or
something right
you really only need to read the first
few chapters of that book to
radically change the way you think about
statistics analysis
probability theory if you've never been
exposed to it
we can tell that tim hasn't been reading
too much because he still believes in
absolute probabilities rather than just
very close to zero or one
zero one today on his prior zero to one
probability that's not the only
formulation there's equivalent
formulations of probability theory where
it goes from minus infinity to infinity
or zero to infinity yeah of course all
the other formulas change so the sum
rule the product rule
whatever but uh we don't need them but
we can make it appear
yeah we've got infinite computers we're
fine
cool optical i let me just say one funny
thing
the teacher i had for i think
thermodynamics one or something this
really funny guy used to be a tank
commander and you became professor and
and one day he was doing some integral
and and the integral diverged and he's
so it looks like this explodes but this
is an optical explosion
because i can do this change to it and
now it becomes a convergent
you know integral optical explosion
that's what those infinities are
optical infinity
gentlemen it's been a pleasure we are
going to be back
next week uh where we are going to start
debating
the social dilemma oh
yeah i'll leave that with you peace out
folks
catch you later